what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder for episode two of
the we'll call the new podcast the new
new podcast today i have a special firm
with me today i have wendy from the
movie couple so i have half of the movie
couple
here today because her husband dustin's
not here uh we're gonna get him back
though for sure but everyone say hello
to wendy
hey everybody thanks for having me on
well we can be called the movie singles
for today that movie is sick i have uh
wendy from uh the movie singles today
uh but they're awesome i was on their
channel i think last week maybe even
yeah last week and uh it was a blast um
her and her husband are
good friends of mine and uh wendy's my
kpop bestie too so yes we are uk pop
fans out there we're going to see
straight kids soon
but more importantly we all watch doctor
strange at the multiverse of madness
together
and that was a fun time
yelling standing up and clapping during
the whole entire thing uh
just in case anybody hasn't seen doctor
strange the multiverse madness we will
be talking about spoilers and we're
pretty much gonna dive right into them
so if you haven't seen it and you
actually care about the spoilers sorry
come back after you've seen it
but for those of you who are still here
whether you've seen it or you haven't
you don't care about spoilers we're
going to talk about the illuminati and
their deaths
uh because they were pretty brutal but
most importantly
i think it was just so cool to see the
illuminati like when they came on the
screen like we already knew right but
like how did you feel when they first
came on the screen when they're
introducing everybody i mean that was
just so cool
there was a lot of anticipation i feel
like i physically was shaking just a
little bit not to sound overly dramatic
but you know i try to stay away from the
the trailers after we all heard and it
was kind of you know amongst the fans
confirmed that it was sir patrick
stewart's voice and my friend
immediately texted me he said so we're
getting illuminati i'm like are you
saying this as a rhetorical
as a fact or are you asking my opinion
because this is marvel so they can kind
of
you know fade and swing that bait and
switch but they can stretch things up or
it may not be i don't want to over hype
myself in my head before seeing this so
when the reveal came
and they uttered the words illuminati
i'm like here we go and i was very
curious to see who was going to be
sitting in those seats it was a great
moment probably one of my faves
oh yeah like definitely like top mcu
moment like of all times it's funny
though i actually remember texting you
and you were talking about like yeah
yeah i saw like i'm trying to avoid
trailers and spoilers now i'm like oh my
gosh don't watch my latest video like
don't even look at it because in the
thumbnail i had captain carter shield in
there
oh did you yeah so because they showed
it in the trailer yes so to me anytime
they show something trailer like it's
it's fair game right
so like they showed professor xavier's
chair so like
everybody knows like we were text today
about my video that was about the
illuminati i'm like i put professor x in
the thumbnail one because a lot of
people have already put it in their
thumbnails already but two they they
showed him in the trailer you heard his
voice the first trailer and then the tv
spots literally showed his chair
so i'm like fair game like if marvel
throws it out there it's freaking
exactly right
but
this makes me so excited obviously you
know
they all died um
but we should be getting our own
illuminati soon right don't you think
like especially now since doctor strange
is like
oh this was this team like we should
probably have this team what do you
think
i'd like to think so but i'm curious as
to who we are going to get on the seats
of the illuminati because i feel like it
may not be exactly the same
as 838's illuminati but i'm holding out
hope that we're going to see john
krazinski again
on those seats the smartest man i mean
they even mentioned the baxter building
right in the film and they just kind of
dropped that like they glazed over it
they just said it like a throwaway line
i'm like did he say baxter yeah yeah i i
think that building was the baxter
building that they were in right
i have a quick question for you though
sure yeah when they were
uh fighting wanda
who is
of the statue you know how there's a
yeah who is
there's actually a few of them too
we'll get to that in just a bit but
first a big thank you to betterhelp for
sponsoring this video sometimes life
gets pretty hard and sometimes you just
want somebody to talk to that's where
better help comes in in this chaotic
world that we live in sometimes it's
pretty easy to feel overwhelmed or feel
some type of anxiety whether it's work
school family or relationships sometimes
you just want somebody to talk to and
it's also really good to check up on
your mental health well better help is
an online resource that allows you to do
just that connecting with a therapist
online from the comfort of your home
they have a broad range of officially
licensed therapists over 20 000
therapists in their network which makes
it very convenient to find a therapist
that works for you and you can change
therapists at any time for free i know
it can be a lot easier to receive
therapy from the comfort of your own
environment and it's not just therapy
sessions you can message your therapist
at any time check out some information
that may be useful to you and schedule
your appointments all from the same page
head to betterhelp.com cosmic to answer
a few questions and get paired up with a
therapist within 48 hours you'll also
get 10 off your first month by clicking
the link in the description down below
that's better help h-e-l-p dot com slash
cosmic so there were a few different
statues so one had like that circle over
and there's a guy in it and i was like
is this hercules because it's like a
really buff guy right there were rumors
going around like several months ago
that hercules might be making his way to
the mcu plus we have like zeus
coming and for them and thunder so i'm
like maybe that um but then there was
like the ones with the wings
yeah so i'm like who the heck were those
people right i can't figure it out the
only people that i think have wings are
warren who is angel in the comics okay
right yeah exactly but i'm sitting there
but there were like four statues i think
of like people with wings so i'm just
like is this decorative like
or are these fallen aluminum previous
illuminati members oh maybe right it's
possible i'm waiting for them to come
out and say something about that because
i feel like speculation could go pretty
crazy with that like i'm already like
yeah it's the x-men like you know what
i'm like uh but but what's crazy is
that's not too far-fetched of an idea
because obviously professor x was there
mr fantastic with a fantastic four so i
don't know i wish i could answer your
question i've been thinking that i've
been thinking about that a lot too
yeah same here i just like i don't have
a i don't really have a definitive like
okay this reminds me of xyz like it's
it's so
it's large but it's also at the same
time vague
that i'm just like it's probably it may
be just the nothing and you know us fans
we like to tin foil had it and kind of
sing it's mephisto
i think that's who it was right there
confirmed
well and you also have to think like it
is the baxter building
um
he is an intellectual he is a scholar mr
fantastic it could just be
other people from
some point in time and who knows
what has happened in this timeline it
clearly looks more advanced
um so these could be other scholars
right who have done many important
things just for society
in that universe who knows yeah
absolutely we'll find out in the next
mcu movie yes and i want to know
what statues will our illuminati put in
their building and which building will
it be who do you think would form the
illuminati in our
universe 616.
uh well if you asked me this pre
chadwick boseman i was going to say chad
bozeman so i don't know about that now
um
i actually i like that answer sorry i
like that answer because in the comics
black panther is the one who decides to
not join the illuminati so i think it
would be cool to switch it up yeah and
have him form it
which would make sense to me i mean this
is it's so sad that this is kind of like
a moot point right now
because of what happened sadly
but um we'll see what happens in black
panther too and how if there's a new one
yeah or i guess they could you know if
you want to talk about somebody who
is smart we obviously we haven't been
introduced to a mr fantastic in the 616
yet so um other smart individuals um
shuri could be one sure um we have the
hulk professor hulk yeah but also you
know be i mean i don't think either of
them technically have sat on the seats
of illuminati ever
um
it's kind of hard to say because i would
have say i would say iron man but that's
also impossible
it is um
so we know that neymar is coming in kind
of forever yes uh so he's on it in the
comics and
i heard that
they were considering namor for the
illuminati and multiverse of madness
they were
so we'll talk about this because i think
this is really really exciting
michael waldron the writer did want tom
cruise to play iron man
and i think he i just read like i read
about before but i like just read like
in detail today he said it was
availability that's what it was
so
like
that could have happened
so in a multiverse where i actually
believe incursions are going to start
happening
maybe we do get a tom cruise iron man
and
you because you have to wonder like
who created those ultron bots
right was it mr fantastic
i had the thought that
maybe in that universe tony stark
instead of working with bruce banner to
build ultron worked with mr fantastic
and since he's smarter because he's the
smartest man alive they actually pulled
it off
that's my theory yeah so i think there
is an iron man there somewhere
maybe he's a little bit too arrogant in
that universe because maybe he is
superior iron man and he thought i'm not
gonna join your stupid illuminati team
right didn't have time for it maybe
somehow that does
drift into our universe and we do get an
iron man again
if only even for like maybe a movie
yeah but i would like to see
a iron man on it which i don't think is
gonna happen like you said because
they're not gonna just be like oh robert
downey junior dad and
in game here's another
iron man right yeah irreplaceable even
if it's just by a different actor and
it's a whole different persona right and
we're getting the iron heart but that's
you know not the same
yeah so it's interesting to think like i
keep thinking about in the within the
existing superheroes that we've met so
far within the 616 like who could do
this and a lot of them unfortunately
aren't with us anymore those were all my
choices i know
yeah and it's like you're not gonna have
one to be a part of it because
she just kind of did something maybe our
doctors change is the one that starts it
i think our doctor strange probably has
to and i also have a theory that i'm
going to do like a video on later i
think like the x-men and the fantastic
four can't really be ignored now because
doctor strange has run into them now i
was actually hoping that
the second post-credit was gonna be
something about john krasinski being mr
fantastic oh something gosh because it's
not confirmed i mean it's confirmed in
the way that he was he did play a
version of mr fantastic right and i'm
holding out hope just because it seems
like there are multiverse versions of
themselves still look like the ones that
we know maria rambo looks just like mary
rambo
and you know captain carter and etc so i
would like to think so but he was also
so hesitant
on being a part of a superhero franchise
that it's still
making me think i guess i just don't
want to get my hopes up for it to be
squashed i'm gonna be like that was a
one-time guy sorry yeah really not gonna
do it and the reason why he said yes it
was because there was no commitment
i i hope not
i just because i
i really thought it was perfect
i i really it's really funny like he
looks in the movie exactly like the fan
art of him looks
right i mean like it's like all the fan
art was like super accurate like this is
actually how he looks um
but really i think just like his whole
demeanor
and like i i rewatched some of it today
like some clips that i have and when
they introduce him and he comes out and
he turns around like the way he looks at
stephen
because you know hi it was his friend
doctor strange was his friend the one
that they had to kill was his good
friend he formed illuminati just became
corrupt he turns and looks at him and he
just smiles and he's like steven and
then stephen cracks a joke
because uh mortals like of the fantastic
four and uh strange is like didn't you
guys top charts and whatever and then uh
you they briefly go back to him he's
just like
he gives like this smile and this nod
kind of like yep still the same old
steven strange cracking you know jokes
making wise even though it's a different
one like so i'm like that's like that's
really cool like those subtle little
things that they put in there i'm like i
love that like i really love that and i
think he did a really good job so he's
on my roster for the illuminati in the
rmc in 616.
i think i think doctor strange just
probably has to be the one to form it
yeah he's got to be the one to form it i
think he will probably
most maybe reach out to captain marvel
uh and i'm saying this because rambo was
technically a part of it so if we want
to apply that you know to our 616
then there is that but then
if we're looking at captain carter who
doesn't exist really in the you know not
in the age that she is um
neither does captain america so do we go
with
falcon i don't think so that was captain
america i i don't think so i was seeing
where you were going with that yeah i'm
sitting there like i just don't know if
that's something he'd even want
that yeah probably not because he has
very much
like
a lot of steve rogers instilled upon him
like in him
and
i don't think
i really don't think so
i don't think so either but then you
have to think of like okay like you said
like who do we have left like i don't
think hawkeye like
sorry there's not much he brings to the
table
he's doing christmas with the fam right
yeah i think hawkeye is great for who he
is uh
but if you're looking for like like
really powerful people i think maybe
professor hoke was right
um and i and we know that he's gonna be
normal again because we've seen those
pictures from she-hulk they released
them
so i definitely think having someone
like him hopefully he can still hulk out
yeah yes
so having someone like him would be
great uh so mr fantastic doctor strange
the hulk i do think someone from wakanda
should be a part of it because i do
think if chadwick was here yeah it could
be sherry i i think he might think it's
a good idea because he's the one who has
all the vibranium and all the resources
and they're just now opening like
wakanda to to everybody well i guess not
just now because of the blip and
everything it's been a long time but
before that it was like brand new for
them
i feel like they would want to have like
a supreme authority to stop
people from wanting to come to to
wakanda wanting to come to earth and to
get the vibranium right since we're
showing the world now what vibranium is
we need to have some things in place to
make sure bad people don't get it
so but if we want to like talk about
like so the illuminati is really like
the leaders of each group right so tony
stark with the avengers uh mr fantastic
fantastic four
i don't know if they're going to do in
humans in the mcu i i don't think
especially with changing this marvel
story
right yeah
i think that was a nice treat for us for
the movie right i don't think they will
continue on with the main mcu storyline
yeah
sally don't either but i do think the
illuminati will eventually come because
i i think this ends with secret wars
with
a bunch of different incursions going
into and they all end up in like one
one universe which i i would be really
really pumped to see wow
yeah that's gonna be incredible to see
on screen if that's what we get they're
hinting at you know big things to come
it's just another slow build up you know
but uh when it when we do get there i
think we're all gonna flip out oh me too
i would actually like to see a
multiversal illuminati
like one person from each universe
like a representative from everybody's
universe right like comes together in
one universe or maybe outside of the you
know space and time somewhere and
they're the ones that are like we
monitor the universe with the watcher
the watch could be a part of the two you
know and uh you know i think that would
be probably like the coolest thing and
then like maybe a little bit further
down the future a few years from now
they get together like maybe like a
post-credit scene there's a bunch i'm
getting together and just be like all
right we can't stop it like all of our
universes are colliding what do we do
like we can't stop it i think that would
just blow everyone's mind illuminati's
assemble yeah exactly exactly because
you gotta they gotta go bigger right
yeah uh they make it bigger than in game
so yeah it's got it's gotta be bigger uh
and there's i mean it's like it's like i
have questions but yeah to try to right
now using the current roster to fill up
the seats of illuminati's without them
having introducing some other characters
first
makes it a little tough like we can make
arguments for certain characters but
it's just like i don't i don't know but
i think neighbor is a really really good
start
yeah i think uh
uh it depends on how the story goes down
because i think he's gonna be fighting
with wakanda at first maybe
but i mean they kind of fight in the
comics too i mean they really fight in
the comics but
um
i think he would be cool and i think
we've talked about some cool people as
well i i guess the big question is now
like
we know the fantastic four coming but
are the x-men coming soon you know like
i hope so me too especially with
patrick stewart coming back as professor
x he said he wouldn't mind doing more i
know he said it no
so if he's available like you gotta you
gotta use them so to me though that
seems like more multiverse stuff because
he can't come back and play
like the permanent professor x in our
universe
well no because he's not patrick stewart
the actor is unfortunately not immortal
right he'd like him to be but yeah uh
and i don't know if they want to kind of
go back and say okay well then we'll use
the other
professor x but then they have to
establish that there's a lot of like
dots i feel like they have to connect
because i was really hoping
and here's a little something you and i
kind of texted about this earlier but it
kind of bumped me out a little bit with
the illuminati because it was so short
and i get it that's not the premise of
the movie um even though it was a good
treat for us to see but
i wanted the scene between wanda and
professor x to go a little bit longer
than what we got
i wish he had mentioned something about
her father or something about i know
i wanted to see where that was going to
connect because so far in both wanda
vision and age of ultron they have not
alluded to the fact that she is mutant
the her father right after meeting her
meeting him in one division does not
seem to be of
a mutant of any kind right so how are
they doing this is what i'm curious
about i know i was curious about that
too especially after ian mckellen's uh
tweet did you see that uh huh i sure did
i had a daughter had wanted to be like
i'm like is that a hint next movie what
is this movie
both of them coming back yep and she's
already basically said like
oh yeah like what's next for the scarlet
witch like we'd love to hear your
thoughts like
basically like the way she's she's like
you know a lot of things could be next
so i'm sitting there like okay well
you're clearly not dead like
you know because you're you're cle and
there's rumors that she signed like
another multi-deal contract so i'm like
i definitely don't think she's going
anywhere people love her
and she's really powerful i think going
that route though with magneto being her
father
even though eventually they read it in
the comics but that whole story line in
the comics where you know quick silver
and wanda are
the son and daughter
of magneto i think that is just
i think people would love that and i
think people who aren't like comic
scholars who don't know the stuff about
the comics would like freak out even
more because he'd be like what
like what do you mean like because we
went through
you know from age of ultron all the way
you know to want a vision to hear
no mention at all like you said and then
all of a sudden it's like what do you
mean magneto's her dad it's like a
surprise that would be a really cool way
i actually think to bring in the x-men
if maybe they noticed what happened yes
with wanda right and uh now all of a
sudden like almost like a um like
x-men three
where magneto goes after gene but so
does professor x like maybe like kind of
one of those things and then we can even
have an interaction between magneto and
professor x where
they're just kind of like professor x is
like your daughter is like on the loose
or something like that i think that
would be like crazy
that would be insane i think
yeah i can't wait to see where they
decide to go with wanda story um because
that's kind of the next i don't know if
they'll probably not give it to us in
phase four probably phase five because i
think we're gonna end phase four with
fantastic four so
very excited to see that and i think
once that's established then we can
maybe start exploring
uh the x-men how we're gonna bring them
in i know a lot of fans want to see it
being brought in by deadpool which i
think will be hilarious and perfect yeah
but we also don't have too much update
on deadpool 3.
it's true yeah i mean we know it's we
know it's been working on and i really
wanted a deadpool
post-credits scene i feel like it just
it would have been perfect for
multiverse of madness like just like
because they already made the joke with
bruce campbell
like i feel like that could have easily
been a deadpool joke just him like
looking through a star portal that maybe
she forgot to close oh my god oh what's
this place
and he just like comes and like that's
all you really need is him poking his
head going oh where's this and he just
goes in and it just closes behind him
and there you go he's in the manha zoo
that's all you really need and michael
waldron even said the writer he he said
they discussed it but ultimately it
didn't fit and i'm sitting there like
post-credits scene would have fit better
than bruce campbell like but
yeah you can't always get what you want
yeah i guess and unless they have
something else in you know coming down
the pipeline for him that they feel
maybe works a little bit better
um but i don't see like
a deadpool cameo in thor rag not not
ragnarok but love and thunder yeah just
that would that really wouldn't fit that
wouldn't make sense yeah i feel like the
like the multiversal movie would be the
purpose
to do it right it could have been it but
i also like the movie also wasn't what i
thought it was
because it's gonna be more multiversal i
thought it was going to be a lot more
multiversal
yeah i thought we were going to see like
60 different cameos not like having a
lot of screen time or anything but like
they go through uh like 60 different
multiverses and they just see people and
it's like oh look here's some you know
here's iceman
you know
kitty pride like yeah you know you just
randomly see people right they don't
even have to talk you just like kind of
observe and just like oh wrong universe
and then you leave and it's like you saw
him for like a half second but you saw
him you know what i mean
so that's kind of what i thought it was
going to be yeah i
in the same vein i feel like i kind of
would have liked them to hit different
universes different multiverses and
stayed in them for a little bit longer
they obviously mainly focused on the a38
and then whichever universe it was that
um we saw the doctor strange with the
dark hold and then back to hours uh yeah
i would have i think they could have had
the time to do it
so it's a bit of a bummer and i don't
know if that has to do with anything
else like
copyrights comics and like that could
have played a role in it i don't know
but i feel like deadpool kind of have
done it in the past remember when they
did like a quick oh yeah yeah like they
were able and i get it that's all fox
but
a lot of things are under the disney
marvel banner now so i'm surprised they
didn't utilize it unless they you know
title aside their work this is a true
doctor strange sequel and a follow-up to
one division yeah do you think the title
was a little misleading or
yes and no yes and no i think in our own
heads as fans sure when we hear
multiverse we're like oh my gosh
especially after watching what if those
final couple episodes the possibility is
really endless and we started to get
excited you know as fans the x-men
fantastic four the illuminati oh my gosh
all this is coming um when we need to
finish telling dr strange's story and
wanda story up to a certain point before
we can progress on to the story so i
understand what they needed to do with
the storytelling but i think it kind of
did set up the fans to get super it's a
catchy title i'll tell you that
like if the tickets came out the same
day as the title reveal i would have
bought my tickets that day no taylor
necessary right i think um
i agree with you i think maybe the
as fans like you said we might have
misplaced the madness because i actually
think the madness was kind of referring
to
wanda and just specifically doctor
strange and his variants yes um whereas
we thought
well
the multiverse is really what's going to
be thrown into madness like
worlds colliding and just chaos
everywhere that's what i that's what i
thought and that's like like you said
it's a catchy title it did its job
uh i just think we might have maybe
misunderstood or misplaced that madness
yeah but do you think it was
was it a letdown to you that it wasn't
so multiversal
you know what uh i had to really think
about that uh and i'm gonna say no
because i have been
so curious as to
where and i know it's a doctor strange
movie but we're gonna talk about my girl
wanda here for a second i mean it's
basically her movie too it's basically
yeah it's they they share the same
spotlight um where she's been up to
since the that end credit in wan
division you know she had the dark hole
her powers were already um
she's gained more power since and so to
kind of see where she is
and where she is in her head and
how important her boys are to her like
wanda is a character
that ever since we were introduced to
her in the mcu she's continued to lose
foster family yeah she lost her brother
and then she lost vision and then so she
created and i'm not saying like oh yeah
it's okay that this is justifying for
her to you know imprison an entire town
because it's yeah it's not but i get the
grief of it and her mind was so focused
on
that grief that she
hasn't quite overcome and she kept on
chasing it because what else is there to
do you just you want to keep chasing
after it yeah
um because maybe it's something better
than feeling the pain of loss all the
time
um so i've been very curious well and i
also think
when she got the dark cold yeah a little
bit of corruption but like
she had to have realized like she's the
most powerful being in the universe
literally nothing could like get in her
way so i think eventually just
you because even as people in real life
like you get to a point where you're
like enough is enough like i'm tired of
losing like you said you know yeah i'm
tired of losing when i literally have
the power to do whatever i want
yeah i think that's what we saw right
that combination of grief and corruption
and power
yeah
it's yeah she knew how powerful she was
and so she stopped
caring and she said i've lost so much
and um now it's my turn i'm gonna get
what i want so all the lines that she
said like about america
you know taking her power how she
essentially didn't care right that she
she in results of that america would die
and the line that she delivered to uh mr
fantastic like good there's gonna be
somebody who's taking care of him i was
like wow
right
okay so um i loved seeing i would have
ran away
i'd be like you know what i'm out you
know what killed me
portal real quick let's get out of here
but yeah um so it's been really great to
see her journey there and it's obviously
not over um i think we're just starting
the wanda journey um and it's nice to
see dr strange's
arc as well to see him
finally giving that bow to wong i was
like okay stephen strange
yeah
he's growing
he's growing little by little maybe he
doesn't have to be the one holding the
knife the whole time i know well he let
it go at the end where he you know was
like it's american chavez that has to do
it you know yeah like fantastic i'm here
to tell you
you can do it you know that was pretty
cool all right well the last thing
you'll end on we're just going to keep
it going fantastic four they're coming
right i mean that's we just found out uh
that the producers for moon knight are
going to be producing uh that as well
now they just lost john watts it was a
pleasant departure he just you know he
did the three spider-man films needs a
break so they're gonna find a director
soon and start doing scripts and
everything but of course
we just wonder who the cast is so i'm
i'm hoping kruzenski and i think we've
established so you're hoping krasinski
as well any thoughts on who you'd like
to play sue storm
and the thing and the human torch
uh would absolutely a hundred percent
need to have it's a must if we're going
to get krazynski no we are getting
krizinsky i'm saying it we're getting
him i don't care we're going to put it
out there in the universe sorry disney i
don't care what your plan is we're
getting brzezinski um and with that it
we've gotta have
his wife emily blunt as sue storm
because i can already see it like they
would look so perfect
for the human torch i would um
absolutely love to see dakota montgomery
okay yeah i don't think we've seen
enough of him i think he's uber talented
um for the listeners who may not be as
familiar with the name he was the right
ranger in the power ranger movie he also
plays billy in stranger things
yeah yeah and he's just uh and i can see
just his vibe
kind of fits yeah and i think he's he
looks and is young enough to be the
younger brother loves you yeah and then
i don't know this is kind of where i get
a little stuck
so with the thing i always say like
people always say people like oh the
rock and it's like you guys realize yeah
he doesn't have to be this huge guy
though like
because it's a right uh mark ruffalo
isn't the size of the hulk like
you know what i mean like but the hulk
looks great right so like yeah it
doesn't necessarily have to be someone
that's really really huge it could be
patton oswalt for all we know you know
what i mean
i don't think you would make a good
thing no offense pat and you're amazing
at other things but uh
uh i met pat and that uh spider-man no
way home premiere actually it was cool
um but uh
i agree with how do you say it's dakra
that cree i thought it was dak
i thought it was dad oh no no no no i
think it's baker
baker okay
i've seen a lot of fan art of him as a
human torch i'm like yes totally uh i
would also say zac efron but they give
off the same vibes and
i think it might actually be better to
go with a lesser known actor
for that role maybe especially if you're
gonna have krazynski and emily blunt
like
those are huge names you know so i i
agree on that one but yeah the thing i i
don't know i
i don't know if the rock would do a good
job channing tatum
i could see that green
okay man the man's got flexibility like
people don't think he can do like they
think he can just do like dance and
comedy
so much more
now i can think no i'm just thinking of
the thing dancing
i kind of want it now but
that would be cool i i think i try to
think of it's like who would interact
well
with krazynski because you know that's
his best friend ben graham yeah so you
gotta let's get uh let's get uh
michael scott steve carroll let's get
steve carroll
you know what why not dynamic from the
office just like who could be best
friends with him yeah the thing is the
thing that's a tricky one but it's also
i feel like the one with the most leeway
like they nailed it with krasinski and
multiverse of madness i think emily
blunt they would nail it with her sue
storm and then
da da how do you say snake oh daker
like acre with the d in the front gotcha
so daker would
i think it would be great yeah him or
zac efron i actually think would do a
really good job they're like the pretty
boy cocky types you know what i mean
right yeah but they could also be
serious and they both have like i think
the body for it
and uh yeah for for ben grim it doesn't
really matter that much almost as long
as the actor can deliver a performance
of the thing
and with that said if we're talking
about performance and i don't i really
never see this actor in like an actual
superhero franchise because i think he's
got so many other projects that are
lined up but and maybe it's because i
just recently saw the northmen but uh
alexander skarsgard was
him and his 40 abs can be in this movie
dude
yeah it's like i can't
i can't watch anything with him in it
just feel just
so not confident right i was like oh
like jeez
i would almost want him to be like
adam warlock i know we have adam warlock
but like we're silver surfer silver
surfer oh
just because of his body you're on
something yeah
yeah just put that guy in a skin suit
and
yeah you know there you go just paint
them paint them so we'll keep channing
tatum as ben graham okay so
we'll move this card over to the server
territory there we go the silver server
is fantastic four related so we we just
solved uh and then liam neeson for
galactus
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
yes right yeah i love that so um
we just we just solved it for you right
there marvel uh we have john kozinski
who you already got but we're gonna
throw his wife in there for uh sue storm
invisible woman we got daker
for human torch uh channy tatum for the
thing
we have alexander skarsgard for the
silver surfer and we have liam nielsen
for the voice of galactus i think that
would be perfect i think that would be
really perfect
so i i with the fan the fantastic four
are coming i really hope we get the
x-men soon and with that we have two
more groups for two more members of the
illuminati and hopefully we see them
some pretty soon as well and they get
more time and hopefully they don't they
don't all get just
destroyed
by something from scarlet witch again or
something never
it'd be funny if like they formed a new
illuminati and then like something
happened in the scarlet witch is like oh
i've beaten y'all before you know like
something like that the first time right
exactly like a little pun like that like
it would be the first time that i came
in conflict with the illuminati so yeah
yeah
but hey wendy thank you so much for
joining me today on this channel on the
show on the podcast all whatever i'm
calling this doesn't have like official
name it's just
the podcast but if y'all have not gone
over to the movie couple please do so
we're gonna link it everywhere down
below in the description and then pinned
comments we'll put their tags and
everything right down down there please
go subscribe to them and if you guys are
on social media be sure to follow them
as well wendy thanks so much for joining
me today we'll get dustin back on here
yes the other movie single will be back
yes
and thanks for having me of course
anytime
we will oh you want to give us a little
woof woof to end it oh my gosh one two
three
wolf
perfect thanks